what up space fam goals in here for
anime uproar and today we're going to be
talking about more epic revenge moments
in anime I said that I would make the
fourth installment if we got 5,000 likes
on the best revenge moments in anime
three and we already got over 9000 likes
which is amazing I'm glad you guys have
been enjoying this series so much if you
want to keep it going make sure to smash
that like button if we get 5,000 likes
again I'll get started on part 5 ASAP if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is really important hit that
notification bell because you will miss
future videos if you don't as always
leave some of your favorite revenge
moments in the comments and they could
make it into the next installment for
more anime content and important updates
on new seasons follow us on twitter and
instagram at anime up drawer there will
be some anime and manga spoilers in this
video so if that bothers you you've been
warned now without further ado let's
jump into it let's start with one of the
most epic characters in anime Lord s
Kannur himself vs. esta rosa to give a
brief background to this revenge moment
Mele Otis was recently killed by a
serosa it turns out that Mele Otis is
practically immortal and will eventually
come back to life but the fact remains a
Testarossa killed him he put blades into
each one of his seven hearts bond tried
to stop esta rosa but he was powerless
while it's already weaker than Estero so
at this point but esta roses commandment
of love is especially tricky
everyone who hates him is rendered
powerless they won't be able to inflict
any harm
after killing our protagonist and the
leader of the seven deadly sins without
a problem as cirrhosis seems pretty
untouchable if you know esken or well
you also know that Merlyn and Mellie
Otis are the two most important people
in his life they accepted him when
everyone else viewed him as a monster so
there's no doubt that s Kannur has a
powerful motive for revenge that's the
setup and now let's jump to the fight
itself esta rosa is just acting like an
arrogant untouchable dude and with good
reason
bond is there along with some other holy
Knights and he tells Esther also not to
talk about love after killing the
captain however bond and the rest can't
do anything they can't grasp their
swords clench their fists or even walk
towards Estero so because of his
commandment they hate him and as a
result they can
harm him just as Estero says pitying the
people in front of him and is about to
quote unquote save them from their
suffering
esken or maces appearance he walked
towards a serosa and Estero so with a
bored look on his face asks why his
commandant isn't working on Eskin or
Eskimo response why should it
I don't hate those who are weaker than
myself I pity that and quote as the
moral the story is praise the Sun and
smash that like button
moving on to Goku and his fight against
Frieza one of the most epic and iconic
fights of all time in any media I
watched this fight before I even knew
what anime was this revenge has
everything you could ever wish for
it has a villain who is as pure evil as
you can get freeze a destroyed Goku's
home planet along with his father he
practically killed his entire race when
Goku was still a baby
so this revenge was long in the making
the opponent is insanely strong he can
destroy planets while sitting down and
no one is even a match for him for the
longest time leading up to the finale of
the fight he also shoots piccolo and
crushes Krillin Goku's best friend to
death using what looks to be the force
not to mention that he tried to kill
Gohan many times
Goku son the stakes are as high as they
could be literally the whole universe is
in danger including eventually planet
Earth if Goku losses despite after
Frieza kills Crillon and is about to
kill Gohan we get the most iconic
transformation of all time Goku becomes
the Super Saiyan of legend his usually
black hair goes up and becomes blond his
eyes turned green there are a few 80's
and 90's kids if any who would not
recognize Super Saiyan Goku this wasn't
just an epic moment in anime this was a
historical moment all of a sudden Frieza
the strongest and most prideful being in
the universe starts getting rekt the
tables are turned in a way that Frieza
could never have predicted for the first
time he tastes the spare his attacks
seem to have no effect on Super Saiyan
Goku and he's deathly afraid of Goku's
attacks suddenly Goku is the calm one
and the mighty Frieza is freaking out
and panicking
Goku flexes on Frieza so hard when he
let's him launch a powerful laser beam
right at him he doesn't move and just
lets himself be hit Frieza could have
put all the energy he could muster into
that one attack and Goku is still fine
after it he even smiles and says so the
monster who can destroy a planet can't
even destroy one little man and quote
this is freezes nightmare his whole life
he was way stronger than everyone and
now a member of a race he always looked
down on is not just beating him but
humiliating him Frieza being the good
villain he is doesn't simply accept his
loss he uses his brains and comes up
with a plan to win if he can't kill Goku
that he'll destroy the planet Frieza can
survive in the vacuum of space this is
his only shot to win and he takes it
after the planet begins self-destructing
Frieza finally shows 100% of his power
after what seems like a billion
transformations Goku could potentially
kill Frieza before he attains full power
but being the mad lad he is he wants
Frieza to reach his full potential he
wants to check out the most powerful guy
in the universe at full power because he
might never get this chance again this
always makes the revenge all the sweeter
when the opponent knows that they gave
it their all and it still wasn't good
enough
after the namekian dragon saves the
others Super Saiyan Goku and full power
Frieza are left to duke it out on an
exploding planet Shaolin doesn't get
much better than this the fight
commences and all of a sudden Goku quits
ironically this is absolutely the
biggest flex he could pull off in this
situation he quits and get this not
because he's losing but because freezes
hit his peak and his power is dropping
fast he doesn't see a point in fighting
him anymore
Goku is literally saying freezes too
weak to even fight and in this way he
completely destroys what remained of
freezes pride he says what's the point
of rubbing it in and tells Frieza to go
off and cower someplace
of course Frieza can't take such
embarrassment and shoots his own version
of destructive disks in an attempt to
cut Goku in half all the while Goku says
that Frieza is just hurting his own
confidence with these stunts then Frieza
gets cut in half by one of his own
axe and worst of all coke we even tries
to warn him to dodge it as Goku puts it
it's truly a pathetic end for the
strongest being in the universe Frieza
even begs for help and Goku actually
obliges he gives him some energy so he
can save himself instead of finally
getting a clue and being thankful for
Goku's insane level of mercy Frieza
tries to use the energy Goku gave him to
launch an attack that will kill him and
finally Goku has no choice but to finish
him off he utterly destroyed the mighty
and arrogant freezes pride and it's
perfect that a saying of all possible
beings accomplish this I can't think of
a greater fall than going from being the
most powerful and arrogant being in the
universe to begging for your life this
revenge moment had history the ultimate
evil the largest of scopes the most
powerful of opponents the most arrogant
of opponents the most compelling of
motives the biggest of humiliations
and arguably the most iconic
transformation of all time for all of
these reasons this moment easily
deserves to be considered one of the
best revenge moments in any medium the
next moment is a rather interesting one
because it takes place between two
villains mainly between overhaul and
chigan aki from my hero academia from
the first meeting these villains didn't
get along well we're all super arrogant
and looks down upon the league of
villains and shigaraki he calls their
rendezvous spot and unsanitary dump
overhaul aka Chi Chi Saki is the Yakuza
captain of the eight precepts of death
he seems pretty cool and dangerous from
the very beginning the dude is crazy
ambitious after all for one is defeated
by all might she suck he wants to become
the new leader of the dark side of
society he wants to rule over all of the
villains including the League of
villains the young man wants to take all
for one's place she got aki similarly
wants to be the next leader and he tells
Chiaki as much she got Aki's league of
villains has more clout than the eight
precepts anyways overhaul is not
impressed though he hasn't come to join
the league of villains as shigaraki
thought he asked shigaraki if he has a
plan he explains that a goal like
annihilating the Society of Heroes
without a plan is useless he implies
that shigaraki doesn't know what he's
doing he doesn't know how to use P
and manage an organization he points out
how stained muscular and moonfish were
all-star players but she got aki didn't
know how to use them so they got beaten
and caught beyond calling into question
sugar rockies leadership skills he also
says the league of villains is made up
of wackos insulting them all he says
that you need a plan to make your goal
into a reality and he's the man with the
plan and then he tells the league of
villains to join him since as the next
leader he'll put them to good use this
guy's definitely got balls he walked
into the most famous and strongest
villain organization in Japan insulted
them and told them to come work for him
the dude goes on to kill Magni and
destroy mr. compress his arm he then has
his team break through their rendezvous
place he throws down his card and tells
shigaraki to give him a call once he's
calmed down you can imagine how
infuriated shigaraki was this guy came
in killed one of his treasured members
heard another embarrassed him caused
damage to the property and left while
talking down to him the entire time till
she got Aki's credit he didn't lose his
cool and even let overhall leave without
a fight later after overhauls defeat
that's when she got Aki's strikes while
overhaul is being transported to the
nearest villain hospital she got off tea
and his team interfere they defeat smash
thus and hero and get overhaul out of
the vehicle now the tables have
definitely turned Hoover Hall is tied up
and completely at jjigae Rocky's mercy
shigaraki asks and who's going to be the
next leader now evidently taunting chee
sake while he's down overhaul asks if
she got rocky came to kill him but she
got Aki says he's thought of something
even worse for revenge mister compressed
takes one of Jessica's arms to get even
for the arm he lost shigaraki takes
cheese Sookie's finished product the
fruit of his endeavors and then comments
on how a guy who wants to get rid of
quirks shouldn't be relying on quirks
himself he then destroys and cuts off
his only remaining arm like she got Aki
overhauled needed his hands to use his
quirk so now he is in effect quirk las'
shigaraki laughs in his face stating
that all the hard work she sake put in
is now his shigaraki 'he's used
all to gain even more Fame and power the
once arrogant chisaki looks completely
devastated and afraid now as she got Aki
tells him to just sit back and watch
because it's his time in other words
it's the league of villains time to
shine they set off an explosion and walk
away
looking pretty freaking cool like a true
boss
Shigure rocky doesn't look back at the
explosion this was a great revenge
moment because of the unique setup of it
I really liked how it was a villain
versus villain revenge moment heroes as
seen with Goku usually show a lot of
mercy to the villains mercy that they
arguably don't deserve however she got
Aki since he's a villain can be as
brutal as possible with his revenge and
he is this is one of the most
interesting moments in my hero academia
and it establishes shigaraki as a worthy
main antagonist before this I always
thought she got Aki was nothing special
overhaul seemed way cooler than him when
he showed up initially however after
this revenge moment there is no doubt
that she Gaddafi has progressed
significantly towards becoming a pretty
badass villain the character development
makes this revenge moment all the more
epic and that is it for today's video
let me know which revenge moment was
your favorite if you enjoyed this vid
make sure the united states of smash
that like button and share this video
with a friend
remember if we can get 5,000 likes I
will get started on the next revenge
moment video ASAP whatever happens I'm
super thankful that we made it this far
with the revenge series if you haven't
be sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification valve because you
will miss future videos if you don't for
more anime content and updates on brand
new seasons make sure to follow us on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar a
big thank you goes to our patrons over
on patreon who help make videos like
this one possible I especially want to
thank our pro hero to your patrons the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings L dress fitting dolla
beats Anatoli Cassatt's ki alpha do
angel Cruz and team Sparky 65 and are
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
atop all clans Steven and Radha a
lowland autumn Mattie Mac 239 makoto-kun
and the world if you enjoy our work you
can
poor Maura by going over to patreon.com
slash anime up floor and becoming a
patriot today for as little as $1 if you
do so you'll gain name feature in future
videos alongside these epic people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord so check out
patreon.com slash anime uproar link in
the description if you're interested you
can also now join the YouTube channel
and support more content that way if you
prefer whichever way you choose to
support us you can get the same great
benefits thanks for everything and until
next time see you space cowboys
[Music]